hello my name is crystal Joseph and I've
been a screen writer for about 15 years
now I've been working on a current
project for about three years it started
off as a short story for a creative
writing class that I took and about
three years ago a friend of mine came
over reddit and was blown away he
challenged me to create it into a
screenplay or a television series and I
tried to do the television series way
but wasn't gelling when I finally
decided that it would be a screenplay my
imagination took off I can't quit the
screenplay because it's powerful it was
black history with modern-day
Christianity and science fiction because
I love science fiction the working title
Daniel and Ben Daniel the evening before
he is to be ordained a preacher goes
into the bushes with some other men and
that turn on hooves one of our Black
History heroes to strategize on a
rebellion against the slaves Daniel
comes from a freed slave family a freed
slave family they're no longer slaves
but he's so dead against slavery he
wants to fight against him in a
rebellion and it is there in those
bushes that he's turned into a vampire
now his father a very strong
conservative freed Negro preacher
follows his son he's dead set against
this rebellion he doesn't want to do
anything to file these white people up
and yet he finds his son in the bushes
being turned into a vampire the thing he
does to his son to ensure that he does
not kill frivolously as a vampire is
powerful it really is and then we meet
then we made been in 2016 he is the
pastor of a hugely successful megachurch
between ben's birth between ben's birth
and down
birth there was not a male born daniel
was born in 1806 and until nineteen
seventy one that is the first male after
Daniels birth that was born to that
family so Daniel who the undead makes
himself the unwanted advisor and mentor
of Bishop Benjamin and the play is it's
just fantastic I am a devout Christian
and I know the Bible says judge not lest
ye be judged I also know that many
religious people first thing they do is
judge I want to use this screenplay to
show them how you can't judge the
vampires evil and the preacher is good
because of the way I weave the story I
want to challenge their thinking on how
they judge books by its covers or lives
by their covers I find the best times
for me though to write the afternoons
and use the music stirs my imagination
once I get into writing I turn
everything off because I needed to be
silent but afternoon the sun shining
music going and once I get going into it
in total silence that helps me right
that's the best time for me to write
about six or seven years ago I had one
of my screenplays produced it was a
short scream plane it was produced as an
independent film and oh my gosh that was
exciting but the lesson I learned was
this if you sell your screenplay and you
sell it outright don't expect to have
any create creative rights to it parts
of my screenplay that I would not have
changed were changed and kind of
annoying me I mean I was still excited
that my plane was on this screen but I
hadn't learned a valuable lesson if I'm
going to sell it somehow i'm going to
maintain my creative rights or i can't
sell it was a great lesson
my goal is to write great compelling
movies that teach that challenge that's
just fantastic I written over 20 short
plays and three fooling place all of
Broadway all off Broadway but I am a
resident of New York and they were very
successful though very I love writing
and I love directing but plays limits me
I'm limited space I'm limited to prop
some limited to actors screenplays allow
my imagination to soar and when I write
all the limitations are take it off
that's what makes me want to be a
screenplay writer and I'm so excited
about this project you'll hear more from
me very soon take care